[Music]  today we were working on kicks and  techniques and these things sort of  tricks and spins and stuff every day  there's something that's easier and  something that's harder we wanted to  find a style that feels different than  the way that you see most women fighting  and film in general I would say that she  fights like a boy except that diminishes  the fact that she just fights like a  really really strong woman Tess has  thrown herself at this in the most  extraordinary way just incredible  commitment to the physicality of the  part the minute you open the door Wow  someone's got a history Tessa was so  compelling and powerful and mysterious  got we talked so much in Hollywood about  representation of women and we need  really strong stand up parts for women  but we also need women that are in  conflict and are not so great we need  representation all across the board